[Musique]
époux
tiote quand on voit quelle drôle de
façon de voyager
ouais heureusement que les petits bois
tout beau tout on ramène à la maison
[Musique]
st
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font du jardin
public
non ils construisent des tours de béton
à la place des gens qui t'ont soi mais
une seule fleur ne pourra jamais
remplacer tout un jardin d'ailleurs la
pauvre ne résiste pas longtemps
le grand patron
bah oui credo chien est en colère les
arbres lui manque pour vos credo chinois
vous inquiétez pas on les a remplacés
par de magnifiques arbres embêtant mais
ces arbres là ont des failles qui font
mal
[Rires]
[Musique]
bah
allez les petits voient tout débarrasser
nous de ce béton
[Musique]
et maintenant que le ménage effet
apporté les vrais arbres et s'il vous
plaît déroulé le tapis vert et de chefs
ou de joie il a retrouvé son jardin et
on doit être heureux il regarde pousser
les fleurs
[Musique]
attendez ce n'est pas fini
et oui on construit de très belles
maisons
[Musique]
bonjour eh oui finalement c'est pas mal
hein alors c'est d'accord on fait comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention aux eaux les nombreux bêta le
trafalgar
c'est aussi doux qu'une carence au
revoir à tous à tous et merci
[Musique]
et
oui